哇 各位朋友今天台灣股市好恐怖喔
你看 又在跌了
台股大跌 剛才我看的時候
台股大跌
今天剛好收盤 現在剛好收盤
大跌在1100多點以上
台股大跌千點二次崩盤嗎
第二個 納斯大哥也破底
台股trally done
因為台灣股市很難自身失惠嘛
韓國股市也是看起來有點危險 怎麼辦
第三個 美伊有在衝突嗎
美育真的在衝突
這是我最怕的事情
其實前兩件事我都不怕
油價會不會突破100美元
因為看起來
川普一下要發瘋
要打針的了
這些預告
我今天要一次告訴你
重點是大家最怕的是
會不會二次崩盤
會不會跌破4萬2
好 我今天會講得非常精彩
很重要 很重要
你要看
因為今天不論是大股小股
通通跌到骨折
可是這是好事還是壞事
我再一次講個夠
台股本来都要重返45000大关了
但今天又大跌千点
最后崩了1195点
收跌在43654点
投资朋友们都猝不及防
很担心难道二次崩盘又来了吗?
昨天的财报出来后
Google跌了快7%
而特斯拉竟然跌了14%
同时有报道指出
美国再次威胁升级对伊朗的打击
导致油价飙升煤桶冲破100美元大关
投资朋友都想和投资长求救
难道是这些原因导致今天台股大崩盘吗
到底现在该怎么做呢
接下来就交给我们经济日报选股冠军
单季188%的记录保持者
同时也是全台湾唯一百万粉丝
最受欢迎的分析师郭哲荣投资长
投资长好
Lily 各位同学们大家好
我今天要
我們今天提早錄影
因為要靠散那些辛苦的同仁
是
我們同仁很辛苦
一定要辛苦
我們才有好的報酬
我們機效還是很好
哲哲 今天環球晶要跌停板
不好意思
回答快35% 40%了
我們還是賺100%
所以我們這次機效還是不錯
當然你說會像之前那麼好
沒有
可是我新委員房很興奮
所以我今天要靠散那些
應該說全公司
公司全公司
我們要舉辦活動
稍微靠場一些辛苦的同仁
那這就是我要跟大家講
這未來的趨勢
順便我們大家討論一下
未來的趨勢是什麼
等於研討會之類的
好不好
吃飯
吃美食
然後重點是靠場他們
才有新的標股會噴出去
那我一直要跟大家講
我說其實
今天這大盤
現在大盤大概收盤了
給了1195點
怎麼看
投資朋友
我一直跟大家講
我比較擔心的是通貨膨脹
是
因为看起来现在
依然实随之位
可是我觉得
依然比我想中硬
这也是我讲的
十字军东征
可以打一百年
宗教的信仰差很多
很多人是很怕死
但是一提到宗教
他为了信仰而牺牲
他就不怕了
这很尴尬
川普踢到铁板了
那我认为川普会想办一切
想办法一切
会处理这个事情
只是依然比我想中硬
那当然应也很正常
Liwi问你一件事情
有人莫名其妙杀了你家人
杀了父亲
还要跟你谈判
你愿意跟他谈判吗
门都没有吧
门都没有
门不见了
现在就尴尬就变成这样子
他们不相信川普的一个保证
像我刚才讲事情
我说我保证怎么样
大家基本上都会相信
基本上我算是很说话算话的人
你可以打听一下
所以我要讲的是说
OK
這些東西 這些事情
變得很尷尬
那油價
你又把它控制住
荷普之海峽
能怎麼辦
要掐住它
那現在川普最選擇
是至少你荷普之海峽打開
可是又不打開
原油價格又開始拉起來了
11月要其中選舉了
你知道最新
共和黨現在又倒戈第二次了
衆議院倒戈第二次了
214票比208票
有四個人跑票
這四個人跑票
變成巨大的一個選擇
川普不能再動軍
依然的
除非經過我們參眾議員的表決通過
是
怎麼辦
只能轟炸而已
可是我覺得如果依然夠聰明
他會選擇在11月之前
怎麼樣
我在想你一說
11月之前
還是我認為又11月
甚至10月9月之前
怎麼樣
這一個和談
會有進展
你知道怎麼樣
要11月之前嗎
等到11月以後
川普
魚死碗破
我管你的
我魚都死了
碗都破了
我們關係已經回不到過去了
我就可以衝下去了
川普就給他轟炸下去
會更嚴重 你聽懂嗎
是
所以我覺得還是有機會的
什麼東西都是危機
我前天還跟他說
Jokeman
我說人家飛機delay啊
哇 飛機delay
很多人也常常飛機delay啊
可是他很聰明
把他悲慘的過去
悲慘發生飛機delay的事情
哇 拍得自己很慘
然後咧
哇 就有300多萬的點閱率了
那可以跟他賺才幾十萬
到幾百萬的票房收入啊
還有要donate的收入
你知道嗎
還有就是YouTube平台給他的收入
這些東西就是我講的是
你看起來是悲慘過去
人家是利用機會來賺錢
所以台灣股市現在崩了
朋友我怎麼說
我說環球金只要給我跌到1000元以下
我就會買
不用1000元
這邊我就想買
那我怎麼買
這是我的會員的事情
我跟你講的是
環球金只要跌到1000元
因為我跟你講一次
我們就說三五法則嘛
很簡單嘛
基歐股是三五法則
對不對
對
沒有未來股票
商務法則不適用
我說國際價比較沒有未來
我想沒有未來不是它是爛公司
而是股價
可不可以創新高
好不好
OK嗎
我沒有要批評
他們公司
也是一流公司
1030除占1600
現在剛好回檔多少
0.64
就是商務法則就是回檔35%
是
就是應該乘以0.65
差不多
現在回檔多少
來
差不多是35%
35.6
-1
你看回檔35%有沒有看到
有
剛好回答說什麼不正
所以這邊就是老天爺送給我禮物
我就買
大丈夫
瓦就這麼簡單
同學們你要有信心
我在跟大家講一件事
我今天做另外一張圖
我剛才請思想做
思想也蠻績效的
蠻厲害的
來
我們看一下
看一下台股的一個報酬跟績效
看了以後你就知道說
喔
整個你講在前面了
等我一下
來
為什麼我會這樣講
我說你們知道今年台股報酬多少嗎
今年嗎
你猜高一點沒關係
我怕你猜錯了
你亂猜一下沒關係
亂猜嗎
對對對 不要有壓力
感覺
你猜錯了沒關係
可是你不要拖時間
20對不對
20算很多對不對
對
因為本來漲很多
現在拉回來對不對
如果我跟你講50%
50嗎
對 50%
巴菲特一年的報酬也才20%而已
對不對
好 我們來跟大家看這個圖
這是我要講的 來來
我們先來看過去
先來看未來好不好
等一下喔
先來看未來
什麼叫未來
等一下喔
這些圖很簡單
看一下這邊
我說我們要台灣50
因為我們要台股的報酬
台股報酬你比較
台灣股市漲5萬點
跟你
漲到10萬點跟你也沒關係
如果你不買股票的話
那你要買台灣股市
要買到10萬點要賺最多
跟它是有相關的
除了台積電就是台灣50嘛
甚至台灣50更有相關嘛
對
台灣50跟台股的相關係數高達95%
你們要先了解這件事情好不好
容我不好意思有強迫症
稍微把它扣住一下
好 所以你要賺台股的報酬
最好的就是買0050的ETF
上市到現在13%
近5年29%
近10年24%
好 所以我們用
來再看一下這個很重要
因為你現在跌的時候你會緊張
你相信我
你一定會緊張
我們用43000來看
今天收盤價格差不多
我們看一下
好 43多少
43654 很專業
莉莉現在越專業
聽這一段很重要
我們來看
43,654
我减600点好不好
我减600点
我用43来算好不好
好
那我们用13.8%的报酬
台湾50的报酬
没错吗
去换算台股的报酬
这相关性数高到95%的
所以可以来算
我们第七年
就台湾股市到10万点了
所以你现在4万3
你犯个6、7年
10万点的时候不好
OK吗
所以你到底
你要担心是4万3还是4万2
我已经跟你讲了
跌破4万点
甚至4万点左右
我就會砸幾千萬公開買
基本上我現在買台灣50的紀錄
公開的紀錄是100%喔
那是過去喔
我不知道未來怎麼樣
可是過去是
獲勝的紀錄是100%
沒錯吧
好
是公開的紀錄喔
所以我要買
我已經跟你講了
因為我左眼是
我放個幾年就可以
100萬變250萬
我如果放個8000萬
我就變2億喔
下蛋沒
有沒有感覺
有喔
2.5倍不是這樣子嗎
從4萬3到10萬點
不是2.5倍嗎
這怎麼懂
所以我8000萬就是2億啊
就這麼簡單
好
那如果運氣好的話
我怎麼樣
我8000萬會變成2億四
而且在四年內
為什麼
因為台灣50
這五年的報酬是29.2
算高對不對
對
好
這五年報酬是29.2
你們看到這五年是報酬29.2
然後我用13.8算很慢
因為這是23年來台灣50的平均報酬
這幾年報酬是突飛猛進
無非猛進
好
所以我用一般的報酬是
7年內
10萬點
正常的報酬
用最起的這年報酬
4年內就差
12萬點
我不要10萬點
我就10萬點就好了
我87萬到2億就好了
彭教授你在緊張什麼
人家去幹桿跟你語心和桿
為什麼現在這樣說
很多人這樣說
因為去幹桿嘛
你看
現在的
這就是我不喜歡所謂的技術分析
技術分析可以用來設停損
沒有問題
可是技術分析
你不要為了技術分析的技術分析
我問你啊
去杠桿
你本來你可以買1000萬的
你像杠桿來
最好四代同堂
四個代款都有
你1000萬可以做成1億的成交量
你要去杠桿
你1000萬就變成了
只做1000萬的
那是不是就少了9000萬的成交量了
是
去杠桿成交量已經低
那我問你一件事
去杠桿對台灣股市是好還是不好
當然是好啊 對不對
一定是好嘛 莉莉
是好還是不好
是好
一定是好
因為你們一直大二來借錢
那到時候波動就很大
韓國都說啦 韓國的金管會都說啦
哎呦 他很後悔 通過這個
這個槓桿的ETF
所以去槓桿一定好
所以你要四四二非
哎呀 哲哲
這邊啦
拉回反彈沒有量 拉回沒有量
廢話說去槓桿啦
當然沒有量
那去槓桿是不是好事嘛
去槓桿居然是好事
你怎麼會管他到底反彈有沒有量
或者是跌下去有沒有量
懂嗎
懂
既然去槓桿是好事
你怎麼會覺得反彈有沒有量很重要呢
他就是沒有量的嘛
就會減少量了嘛
就會減少量了
去看看就會這樣
所以你的邏輯要對
你懂得說什麼
好 那現在Google也大跌啦
是不是
那Google大跌是什麼原因
我也跟大家講
Google大跌是因為他們去看財報嘛
我昨天就講了
你看今天頭版新聞
所以你也是看我的東西
比經濟日報
比公關時報的頭版新聞快一點
Google破底
Google為什麼要破底
我跟你講 Google不會死
為什麼
你知道為什麼 Google不會死嗎
很簡單
現在很多的知識都在AI
都在那個YouTube影片上面
是
都在YouTube影片上面
那我問你啦
Gameli怎麼咔嚓掉它
怎麼幹掉它
我要查YouTube說
這個博士在講什麼醫學嘗試
這個博士在講什麼股票
投資廟
我直接YouTube丟進去
Google的Gameli
因為Gameli是Google的
Google的GPT
Google的AI程式裡面
他可以直接解讀耶
他可以直接解讀耶可是我把影片丟到什麼TrackGPT他不能解讀為什麼很不好意思因為這Google特別設計的啊
有限制
你懂不懂
這就是他的技術
就是他的技術面啊
你懂不懂
就是他的護城河
簡稱就是護城河
人家說買這家公司要護城河
他的護城河多好
只要YouTube在
影片越多越豐富
AI
只有Google的AI程式
決定來能解析他的影片
它就有一席之地
有沒有人跟你講這些
沒有人啊
市場上 我昨天不是跟你講嗎
我說哇塞
哇 還能幫你看是不是跑整
是不是披死喝
對
然後發現藥不夠的時候
他邏輯還比一般醫生好
真的啦
一般醫生沒有辦法那麼細心
哇 為什麼吃了藥以後
吃了看病毒藥物
為什麼
像莉莉
現在靜靜現在還在痛
為什麼 因為看病毒藥是
不要讓你複製嘛
是
然後第一個
不要讓你複製嘛
那不要讓你複製
原本的病毒還是會在清洗你啊
還是會痛
還是會痛啊
原本病毒還沒有被你消滅啊
所以你吃藥現在沒有效啊
吃個兩天內沒有藥
第二個
有可能醫生開做藥
所以他就你拍給他看啊
我愛他比醫生細心耶
第三個有可能劑量不夠啊
你一般醫生會想要那麼多嗎
沒有你就吃就對了
可是你可以連幾MG算給他看
我的體重多少
我的劑量有沒有算錯
他可以幫你算耶
你懂嗎
這個可以取代很多
很多
不要說取代醫生
幫忙很多醫生
或者是你去看醫生的時候
你知道一件事嗎
醫生會很認真幫你看
但是他做生病的是你自己
你知道嗎
是
很多醫生說是小刀小刀
我開刀的時候醫生也說小刀啊
我覺得大刀耶
對不對
我沒有怪他
那醫生真的不錯
三種那醫生真的不錯
我跟你說肉體是你自己的
那這些AI可以運用那麼多
你聽懂嗎
我還是要講一件事
你們要有想像力
真的要有想像力
我跟你講
我非常有信心
好
來 我們再給你看
那這是我剛才說的
這大概七年嘛 對不對
來 我們今天去跟你們講
我 我跟你講
我今天不要去看很簡單的技術分析
哲哲 你錯了
哲哲 你不是記線沒有手 有手
你們這些小鼻子 小眼睛
真的
如果今天沒有AI這東西
我會很認真去研究記線
這個意義
今天居然沒有
居然居然有AI這東西
我拜託你 我看的是十萬點在這邊
好不好
我看的是雲端
我看的是在這邊
更上面更上面的
我關於這邊回檔還是這邊回檔
反正我最後都要散去
我關於這邊回檔我最後都要散去
懂不懂
知道我可以買最低點 我也希望
但有時候我沒有FU我就不知道
我可以告訴你4萬點跌破
我一定買
有可能提早買 我一定會買
好不好 我一定會買
我過頭一定會買個幾千萬
好不好
買台灣50公開給你看
他是9A 9J是不是
我已經忘記了一下
已經好久沒有公開操作了
好不好
我不會秀對戰當然
但是我會讓你看到券三的進出
這看得出來
好
這是過去
這是未來
我們看一下過去
為甚麼台灣股是現在修正的
台股近年績效
累積表現不太大
這是台股的
我剛才請思雄林一起說
思雄林這做的有沒有含點數
你是用台灣50的績效
還是用台股的績效
我請四雄回答我的問題
我很嚴謹 你聽懂嗎
是
如果用台股
因為我剛才是用台灣50的績效
對
那我過去五年
我不知道四雄是用台灣50的績效來看
還是大盤的績效
那有沒有含初選席
好不好
沒關係啦 初選席就幾百點啦
實際上算不多啦
只是我要是請四雄回答一下
只是我跟四雄對話
你們不同沒關係
因為做事情要很嚴謹
等一下我要順便批判一下
那些害你的外資
花旗跟麥格爾黎
我不要講分析師
因為他們這樣壓力很大
因為這些都是菜鳥
沒有辦法
然後外資也是一個很變態的環境
你聽懂嗎
所以我們公司也有一些外資出身
然後我們公司來當分析師
都很優秀
可是我講那種
就變成很重複的
很頻繁的太壞這些菜鳥分析師
你聽懂嗎
是
所以整整看我節目就知道
原來在股市裡面
30年 當分析師 20年
是對你有幫助的
你借我這句話
會對你有幫助
我今天跟你講很多的金融面
我不要去看那些
我金財我今天也是暫停
不是 要拉起來變成跌停的
I don't care
你知道嗎
金財我也賺100多%
今天就算跌停
我好像要賺90%以上
我待會給你看報酬
這不是
我今天就跟你講
總體金融面
然後為了報酬
來
因為你現在看那個
你現在很注重機械有沒有破
你撐不下去
你聽懂嗎
你今天去借錢
你撐不下去
我要跟你講
比較長期的
那你現在麻醉自己
我又麻醉自己
我自己是完全沒感覺
可是你得要麻醉自己
如果很痛苦的人
你得要麻醉自己
沒有辦法
我說老實話
這個也沒什麼
台灣股市跌20%
我都遇過了
從18000跌到12000
你記得那時候台積電
從800多塊
我想記得多少錢
好像是800多塊
反正一路跌
我說再也見不到
600元台積電
很多人不相信
然後一路跌
跌到500元
跌到400元
跌到380
一堆人笑我
所以哲子講得對
再也見不到600元台積電
真的
結果呢
結果現在台積電2400
請問你500多買還是400多買
他說有意義嗎
聽起來好像是古神啦
到時候賺好幾倍
站前你懂我意思吧
懂
那時候有人笑我
嘖嘖講的對
得到380台積電的時候
真的見不到600元台積電了
然後咧
你們要幹嘛
所以我就是
現在就像那個時候一樣你知道嗎
而且現在我AI真的差很多
現在你知道
有個open AI
他還是OpenAI的員工就說了
他說以後有超級電腦
你要知道AI
照做是AI訓練下一個AI
AI現在要訓練
而且現在有AI層次會逃逸
你知道嗎
AI會訓練下一個AI
AI是不休息的
他唯一的限制就是
網路 然後電流
AI可以訓練AI
所以你那個
以那個
我有點事喔
成長曲線一般也是
哇 我來
我跟你講
我跟你看一下
成長期限大概
如果AI以前東西
一般機器的成長期限
有學習期限這樣子對不對
對
這樣算比較快對不對
人的學習期限這樣子對不對
好
正常人家是這樣子
覺得OK 好啦
快一點大家覺得45度
對不對
好
AI是這樣子
當它已經變了AGI的時候
是
超級厲害的時候
你懂嗎
差這麼多
基本上是垂直的更快
每一秒鐘在進步你知道嗎
居然是這一種等比級數的進步
超級等比級數的進步
現在已經在爆發點了
你為什麼要問我
到底台灣股市有沒有很恐怖
是因為台灣股市現在很恐怖
大盤很恐怖
第一個 通膨在一起
通膨是真的比較麻煩一點點
第二個是什麼
因為大家會怕沒有回報
怕就沒有一個獲利模式
你idea很好
大家講到網路泡沫
可是我跟你講
我剛畫這張圖
我不是畫得很清楚嗎
一般的成長是這樣子
對不對
AI是站直接
網路不會有這種成長
是
你們多用AI就知道
很恐怖耶
我今天只是叫你看病而已
所以我跟你講
你記得一件事
補習班老師
你們記得一件事
我為你們好
你要從事這個行業的人放棄
如果你看不到我看到未來
我告訴你
你以後真的會後悔
補習班的
補教業的
學語言的
學數學的
你相信我要放棄
演員也要考慮
因為一多人像看AI影片的
沒有媽媽都在看的
很多朋友都在看AI影片的
以後只會越來越象徵的
這些都是一樣
價值也是一樣
你們記得這些東西
還有翻譯的
好不好
語言的
就是跟大家講
好不好
你們也會記得
我
是老班你們
或者你有小孩
也要選擇這個行業的
記得叫他們不要選這個行業
好不好
除非他就是不想賺錢
我就跟大家講
好
你要相信我看到未來
我說
這樣做你就要相信我
我說不要這樣做
你要相信我
我說絕對不要這樣做
你就要相信我
好啦
我說台灣股市
我們回到這邊來
台灣股市現在
你有沒有看到
漲多少
資料剛好有Line我
我在講話的時候
便看到它
他說沒有含除全息
沒關係除全息五六百點
我們不要算
好不好
台灣股市現在漲50%
有沒有看到
你有沒有看到
有
來我們再看一下
台灣股市
除了20
所以為什麼我最怕的
就通膨
2022年通膨
8% 9% 我印象中
你聽得懂嗎
我印象中 反正很高啦
TPR 至好有到6%以上
你聽得懂嗎
好 所以那時候從18000跌到12000
很慘吧
對
不是只跌6000點喔
它跌到1 3 什麼意思
假設我從45000的時候
它跌到3萬點
哇
很慘吧
那種感覺 好不好
最慘的時候是跌
跌差不多1 3 30%
所以我最怕的就是通膨膨脹
其他我都不怕
是
AIT2023年有看到AIT26% 28% 25%
對 台股漲幅 有看到
今年50%
所以投資票為什麼現在回答
為什麼現在漲不上去
因為你看清楚
台灣股市就算現在給你
減數是43000 坐收
到12月30日
它的累計績效
它今年績效還是什麼
傲視群雄 傲視其他年
真的嗎
對
所以我要告訴你
本來漲都在休息
所以那時候我不是說
一下跟大家講5萬點
我覺得有點不負責任
但我不知道攻擊誰
攻擊人家了
因為我完全知道股市的節奏
你聽懂嗎
所以我盡量
為什麼我的會員是這一波裡面
應該是所有分析師裡面受傷最少的
因為我覺得節奏很重要
你不能人家現在2萬6
像我跟你講
你問我今年點數
我跟你講可能5萬點可能6萬點
你聽懂嗎
可是什麼時間
什麼時候該怎麼化
你聽懂嗎
不是一窩窩窩的
一定會上或怎麼樣
我可以告訴你
我至少我很確定的是
我認為五年內上十萬點
機率極高
你懂嗎
就像我在兩萬六的時候
告訴你三萬六
我要捐救護車
我擺明就是要捐救護車了
只要三萬六
甚至四萬點
我要捐救護車
你告訴我去年十二月
哪個外資分析師跟你講
今年三萬六
一個都沒有
本土分析師一個都沒有
我講的是事實
只是知道財富自由了
為什麼要一百萬粉絲
以前我不紅的時候
也沒電視台POMO我
我現在紅的時候很多人找我
不好意思 我也很忙
我去做我自己
因為我覺得
你覺得我帥不帥不重要
很多人都說我很帥
但是用我股票讓你賺錢
我股票不讓你賺錢
我一定都不帥
很多人吐槽我
不喜歡我就跟我們對坐
你到底知道
你看到市場上哪一個說
跟哲哲對坐有賺到錢的
你要有本事一直對坐
不然你早就被抬出去中
所以準度最重要
我告訴你 你現在
真的很煩很煩
可是我告訴你是未來趨勢
台灣股市今天漲50%
結論是漲了50%
休息一下很正常
是
老師沒有
我剛才是用10萬點
是用23%來算
四年就10萬點
對
你們很奇怪
你們很多人聽到10萬點說不可能
你知道50%
台灣股市只要幾年就好吧
兩年的不到時間
我們看一下
用43000
就下來報酬
50%喔
兩年多的時間喔
乘算1.5嗎
對不對
再乘上1.5啊
是不是 兩年的時間
真的耶
兩年的時間
兩年 兩年多一點點的時間
就到10萬點了
所以50%是很強的報酬
我講50%是含到4萬3
如果到4萬7 4萬8
前陣子不是到4萬7 4萬8嗎
那不只50%了
所以你們要平常心
果實本來就是這樣子
可是已經有AI的前提下
我真的很有信心
20幾%很正常
我在講一下AGI它的展法是這樣
你們要了解 很恐怖
因為你們很多人不會去用AI
然後我只問你身邊有沒有朋友
一開始已經很多人
你身邊有沒有很多朋友
開始在看AI短劇了
有耶
有對不對
依依有沒有
沒有
你比較少
對
那好 依依是好講實話
小孩你有沒有
沒有
你也沒有
好
但其實有時候滑一滑就會滑到
好 可是我告訴你
那你自己比較不關心老人家
你去問你媽媽
我媽媽說他身邊的現在老人家都看AI短劇你們自己看你們現在底下留言沒們要先二對二嘛那我不管我不管二對二那有沒有這需求存在有就像YouTube YouTube UYT一樣啊
以前是我先看的啊
老人家不看的啊
像老人家誰不看YouTube
誰不看YT
誰會去打開電視台
喔我去轉有線電視台
我要認識二十幾歲的小弟弟小妹妹
跟我講說她不知道什麼是台式
中式 華式啊
真的喔
真的啊
你想你知道
一打開電視就是看YouTube啊
是
是不是
你有沒有人看AI短劇
有
好 那我跟你講喔
那現在是部分有部分沒有
再過一段時間是全部都有
等到那時候呢
股價已經漲到10萬點了
就跟一樣啊
你要記得十幾年前的時候
我都做iPhone手機概念股
每年7月開始做
都一定會
基本上都一定會漲
基本上
現在誰會漲iPhone手機概念股
因為大家都有
是
大家都有
所以你不要等大家都有
大家都知道AI怎麼用的
所以我每天很認真跟你講
我怎麼用AI
你告訴我哪個分析師跟你講這些東西
我再講一次試試
我認為不要說兩年內
四年內很快
基本上五年內
短一點的話四年內
就會十萬點了
你這邊真的拉回要去做多
而且你看看一下台灣股市的走勢
只是去年前年都是漲二十幾%
到目前為止漲五十%
你們冷靜一點
五十%很多了
好不好
所以拉回一點點
我覺得還好
我講那麼多耶
講那麼多東西
跟你講這些東西好不好
所以我會跟你講
我們實在的績效
我們順便跟你講
你看一下
你幫我唸一下我們的績效好不好
唸一下我這些股票的績效
代碼然後賺錢的績效
我喝個水
3374的精彩成本在194.4塊
然後今日最高401
我們績效是106.3%
等一下我們直接講精彩
然後我們賺多少
績效多少好不好
好不好
我們是拿比較低的成本
賺多少%
好
3374的精彩績效
106.3%
6488環球金
已經100%了
6196帆軒也
54.1%
2377的維新
26.9%
5483中美金
23.1%
5347世界先進
11.9%
鴻海
11.3%
2376的基加
6.2%
哇 投資長
真的都
績效非常非常的好
我先跟他講
因為我會員很多
我們是拿比較低成本的
第一次買的金成本
像維新
中美金
我跟他講
210多元
可是新委員很開心
因為我本來買不到
210多元
我還是要叫人家買金
好不好
我講話很實在
我都不怕會員去
我都不怕會員覺得說
啊 只能去說好話
我睡不睡就說好話
最前代的事如果我要說好話
我要胡扯
我會把我的1.74億美債
早就換成台灣50
我會賺到至少4億
你們都可以作證
因為那時候台灣股市1萬7而已
1萬7
OK嗎
所以我要講1萬7 1萬8
中美金這邊拉回
我跟你講
現在台灣股市比較尷尬的是
連最強股票也回檔了
你知道嗎
可是我覺得回檔沒有什麼不好
趨幹幹
我在顯示
可是你看喔
我如果中美金能跌多少
其實中美金今年也沒漲多少
你聽得懂意思嗎
懂
中美金今年也沒漲多少
所以我的股票回漲沒關係
第二個
我要給你一個題材
中美金在怎麼樣
你看這種漲法有很多嗎
你們再冷靜看一下
2327的國具
來這邊多少錢
642對不對
對
我們就看這一段就好了
今年以來642
642在這邊
好
642大概在這邊
這邊
我從200多塊長到600塊
多不多
多耶
很多
莉莉妳懂什麼意思嗎
懂
這邊642
這邊這邊這邊
差不多
抽這邊附近
好 我們再看一次喔
就看這一段就好
再看這一段
請問妳這樣長多不多
多
我現在是642
642有沒有 跟現在價格差不多
對
你懂我意思嗎
國劇到現在還是漲很多
我選的股票是選低基期的
跌下去以後 基期更低
所以我現在 現在的環境很奇怪
我環境不好
環境不好 環境很多人加入我會員
真的
大家要等待低基期
我們來看一下大家對話
甚至我剛才問大家說
有沒有人看AI短劇也是一樣
我喜歡跟你們互動
今天比較晚一點跟大家互動
因為今天比較早錄影
就我們講的我們總是要靠散同仁啦
好不好
來
不融資 不借錢 不槓桿
其實就好啦
是不是
來
可是短劇好無聊 好假
那是你要看哪些短劇
因為短劇很真的啊
你懂我意思嗎
是
OK
來
都在聊天嗎
今天沒有都在聊天喔
來
來來 我們看一下
有看 媽媽都會看
你看 有看AI的表演
你看很多人看AI的表演
你知道嗎
你又沒人看八點檔
為什麼要看八點檔
不需要啊
真的不需要啊
好不好
哲哲可以預測這一波低點嗎
我覺得42000原子彈不會破
最慘就跌破40000點
你知道嗎
這邏輯
沒有互賜
因為我不想賺錢
我想讓你賺錢
因為跌到40000點有些人會受不了
有些人啦
我大部分會有一次受得了
就是42000我覺得大家的底線差不多42000
40000點有些人會崩潰
有些人會崩潰
我的粉絲應該好
可是我覺得部分人會崩潰
可是跌破40000點的時候
我要買幾千萬台灣50的時候
就這樣子
就是老天爺送錢給我
我就買了
錢證子不是要破3萬點嗎
對
就差那1千
就差那1千點
不然你看我又賺50%
馬上賺50%對不對
馬上啊
馬上賺50%
8000萬就變112了
好不好
OK
老人很愛看AI短片
還以為是真的
老人很愛看
所以老人
有些老人會被騙啊
對不對
AI短鏡很好看
你看
OK
我媽也看
所以真的很多人看啊
AI短劇很真的有沒有看到
有啊 每天看AI短劇有沒有看到
你看喔 現在很多人看喔
我覺得AI有比一些真的好看
我媽也這樣說啊
男的帥你的美啊
我為什麼後來知道那是AI短劇呢
因為男的真的太帥了
女生真的太美了
那應該是大影片才對
就是劇作
是
可是沒有聽說過啊
你看 連配角那麼帥還不可能
所以你看 AI漫漫很多
好不好
這跟大家講
所以你看
那這些都是 我想的都是
我只能舉一個最緊張
我總不能跟你講說什麼
分子化學啊
然後那些什麼藥物啊
對醫學的東西
講一句你們會覺得無聊
你們會聽不懂
我不喜歡啊
就像有些分析師會跟你講
哇 我們PCB也好
或只是我被動員計
我每一個做什麼東西的
什麼材質要幹嘛啦
那背起來就好了啦
真的懂會比一般製程的工程師懂嗎
你能說什麼嗎
那沒有意義啊
我要跟你講是評估股價
你懂製程我懂股票就好了
你懂的意思嗎
就像我跟你講
我說國際我們人家在評估
我已經基本面來告訴你
台灣股市五年內會上10萬點
今年多漲五
今年漲了50%
所以他休息很正常
第二個我要告訴大家
你看花旗聽說
最近看網路上
花旗提說重申國際買一目標價1500元
我覺得花旗這個
我覺得很不
729號有法說會嘛
我覺得很過分
為什麼覺得很過分
729號如果
國際法說會
記得一件事喔
2018年立地戰目喔
是
來我真的記得很清楚喔
那時候疊下去的時候也有開法說會喔
如果國具法說會後
股價沒有再漲下去
文史
講文史我們不能講百分之百
百分之九十九產定的啦
你懂嗎
2018年國具也是
也是有股東會
價值的時候也是有法說會啦
那沒效啦
知不知道
投資長會不會有陰影
我有陰影啊
所以你看我賺一倍就走啦
你看我現在真的很開心
不然我陰影啊
這是我成長的養分嘛
因為我有經歷過
所以我不會跟你講什麼目標
要加1500元這種事啦
是
我不會講這些
菜鳥最好經過2018年啦
我就不相信欸
這些分析師最好敢講啦
你了解老闆就知道
1500元喔
我認為他有一定的機率了
那個高層會有人賣股票啦
記得我講這句話好不好
我覺得1500很低
就是除非台灣股市突破5萬點
6萬點甚至到10萬點
他只要有機會再突破1220元
好
那為什麼這個東西來
我跟大家講一句話
我看一下花旗
我直接用AI圖
你看為什麼我AI圖做的特別漂亮
來看一下
我們來看一下
花旗是這樣子
什麼叫股價
就是EPS乘上本益比叫股價
EPS乘上本益比叫股價
就目標價
你知道那邊是嗎
懂
EPS
來為什麼叫EPS本益比
這個需要交嗎
交一下沒關係
很簡單
本益比就是
本益比是什麼東西
你知道嗎
很簡單
本益比就是
股價除以EPS
沒錯吧
叫本益比 OK嗎
股價
容我寫簡體字不要生氣
股價乘上EPS
股價除以EPS叫本益比
就這麼簡單
好啦
小學數學教你
那EPS對不對
對
好
EPS乘上股價除以EPS
EPS
不是等於股價嗎
我把這個劃掉就好了
是
這個劃掉
對不對
沒錯吧
沒錯
這很簡單
所以本億
EPS那本億比等於
股價
等於目標價
好不好 OK嗎
這樣懂沒
他用
2028年的 EPS
2027年 EPS
20年 EPS平均
用到2028年去的
投資票
你告訴我
我連下禮拜我都拿預算
你給我預算到兩年後
不會被搶單喔
那跟年發科不是一樣嗎
對
而且用40倍本益比
然後我跟你講喔
他上面文章裡面的報告寫
同業是給他32倍本益比
你給同業32倍本益比
你給國際40倍本益比
重點是沒有人在寫報告
什麼叫沒有人在寫報告
你又給未來的本益比提高
40倍
你又給未來的EPS
都你講就好啦
為什麼要給未來本益比
因為你現在的EPS沒辦法反應
所以我給未來的本益比高一點
你本益比未來本益比的夠提高
你又還用未來EPS
這樣寫報告的
你們外資這樣寫報告
這樣訓練人的
我都看不下去
我真的看不下去
你聽得懂嗎
懂
你要不要
那你台積電
你要不要給10年後的EPS
有這樣寫的喔
你已經給後年的EPS
你又給一個比較高的本益比
這樣對嗎
你這樣不對
如果是投信出身的研究員
真的經過正統
絕對正統我講這句話
哪有跟你未來EPS
你懂嗎
懂
就那時候為什麼2040之後
我說台積電話等一下
就等
因為你現在本益比已經很高了
你要給他今年的最高的EPS
你懂不懂
你要明年的EPS
我是不是這樣講
你要給明年EPS
你知道下半年嗎
是
那突破2040後下半年
我的邏輯一樣啊
你們在這樣亂搞
你國際你給他後年EPS
在說什麼東西
國際這種是景氣巡王股
除非你認為
哇AI以後全部都通
全部都缺被動元件
我是不太相信
他其實我們可能跟記憶體差太多了
業界都知道
你們每拿2.0 3.0來講這些東西
沒有意義啦
你後年EPS會不會搶單
我看不下去
你後年
後年真的會增加那麼多嗎
擴展會增加那麼多嗎
你去年11元吧
EPS你後年到43元
真厲害
然後43元
EPS應該要增加那麼多了
你後年真厲害
哇塞你比算命神仙還厲害耶
真的
哇你還給他40倍本一比
然後目標價1500
我跟你講為什麼扯
我那時候不是說賣格里很誇張嗎
你1000元你也不講
連發哥不是1000元長到4000元嘛對不對
我今天教你很多基本面喔
我教你非常多基本面喔
1430元1400多元我在買對不對
對
3000元他也不介紹
2000元不介紹
到了5000元多的時候
快5000元的時候4000多元
賣格里跟你講說我用後年EPS
告訴你什麼
聯發科目標價1000元
有沒有看到
一萬 這樣對不對
一樣 而且花期更過分花期對國際更過分應該說花期對散戶規格更過分用國劇來評估我問你喔他用後年的EP值285元
我說最好是TPU晶片
後年都不會被搶攤了
是
國劇也是一樣
你用後年EP值幹嘛
本益比還35倍
還是要良心
投資票
你覺得聯發科
比較有技術層面
還是國劇
你覺得聯發科是IC設計
你覺得聽起來
你告訴我
你覺得聯發科薪水比較高
還是那個國具
我覺得是聯發科
大家都知道啊
聯發科動輒三四百萬以上了
是
為什麼
為什麼要給人工那麼高薪水
因為高技術含量啊
廢話
就這麼簡單
你去問一下國具跟聯發科的薪水好不好
所以聯發科35倍本一比
啊
國具40倍本一比
好啦
哲哲
啊那個春田製作所也有40倍本一比啊
然後咧
你才40倍本一比
你還要做未來的EPS啊
它跟春圓製作者是一樣嗎
你家是真正技術涵量真正的龍頭耶
用後年EPS就算了
你還用後年之後的本益比對嗎
所以我跟你講花期
而且一次發個三篇幹什麼
沒有意義啦
你真的在做研究知道真的在很
我覺得這樣水準真的很不夠
很不夠 很過分
那你這樣講我每個都60倍本益比就好
不要 你們都不要寫報告了
以後就是看我 看我爽就好
我直接60倍本益比就好
我關你EPS要不要寫
本益比可以這樣調的
你一撇子調高了
你調到後年一撇子
給我調那麼高了
你還給我亂調本益比
照你這樣講以後都不要
都不要寫報告了
我看我心情就好了
對啊
我直接寫60倍本益比就好了
不用這麼簡單
我30倍本益比
別人都10倍本益比
別人都多少
股價就變一倍啦
不用寫報告了
我是這樣搞
所以我跟你講
你們真的在寫這些東西
我以前沒有認真看
所以我跟你講
我國具
我要講一個事
國具上面太多
你說會不會在1200
你說會不會到1000元
我不知道
1200很難
但是你說有沒有可能
我就跟你講
因為不是不可能
那就是很難
可能台灣股市要6萬點吧
好不好 我只告訴你
好不好 這樣懂我邏輯吧
可是來一件事喔
就算台灣股市真的到時候
就算國際到時候1200 1300
也不代表花旗這個報告是對的
記得我說這一話
好不好
寫報告不能這樣寫
所以我告訴大家說什麼
當然我只會這樣講話
我說得罪很多人
比如投信經濟人 認很多人
可是我也幫很多人啊
你又 我說你又可以買副班
納斯達克ETF
為什麼
台灣最大的風險
就是台灣地緣政治風險嘛
就是跟對岸打起來
你買副班的納斯達克ETF
我就OK啊
我講話就是說
我講話就是很實在
我一毛錢沒拿
我一毛錢
講這些夠什麼錢
我罵國際
你就會參加我會員嗎
沒有國際的人
現在腿都斷了
你知道嗎
卡了馬起
怎麼參加我會員
好
我要跟你講事實上
然後告訴你
我的邏輯很清楚
我就是買低低位接的
那國際如果再跌呢
跌到300元呢
那我考慮可以再買嘛
600元你也可以買
可是你要告訴自己
有可能談不到1200
你可能到900元 1000元你就一定要走
可能就一定要走 你知道嗎
懂我邏輯就知道在做什麼
那我告訴你為什麼我看好環球經
很簡單 因為成熟製程 現金製程
都會缺細菌源
記憶體會缺細菌源 就這樣子
大力多 你相信我的 我非常看好
非常看好
好 這是我跟大家講的
所以我不論多錯 我講到前面 好不好
這邏輯跟大家講
來
聽者者去年到現在屯的0050
最高獲利超過98
有沒有看到
所以我說你什麼都不懂
你買0050也可以啊
是不是
OK嗎
就跟大家講
謝謝大家
來來
今天申請加入會員
支持認證分醫師
很差跡片的
很爛的報告
不是你報告不能這樣寫
真的不能
你不能用過去
本一筆提高
過來一筆詞提高
我那下了
不能說都沒有人這樣寫
但你寫
後來一筆詞你寫那麼高
他是景氣喜歡滾
你確定寫那麼高
真的但記憶體一樣
技術含量差那麼多
這個
今天跌人這樣怎麼那麼少人
今天少人
因為很多人還是沒有看我的LINE
他們以為兩點半才開始
這個不是這個邏輯不是也
是因為他們以為兩點半開始
不知道兩點半我就結束了
OK嗎
上個禮拜外資還說台積電法說
前週朗年請好買一點
結果現在
剛有人嗆嘛
外資說台積電法說是
來
外資
邏輯對我OK
來 台積電不論任何的時候
都是中山崎買點
因為技術含量太高了
是
所以我並不是
我並不是罵所有的外資
我就case by case
懂不懂
case by case
我這個個性這樣子
大謀有時候會胡扯
可是大謀報告出的好
我還是說OK
你懂不懂
我就說雖然這樣子
他們都不會喜歡我啦
可是我講的是事實
你懂嗎
OK嗎
所以外資
台積電OK 好不好
台積電你說
台積電你說算到後年EPS
我可以接受
可是也是
我也是覺得扯太遠
為什麼我看不到現在他有對手
他現在最大對手是美國
美國要不要搞他 你懂不懂
像以前美國搞Toshiba一樣之類的
好不好
米茲比茲這些的
好不好 OK嗎
黃永慶最近
台灣參加會員少賺很多
之前會員都賺很多
不會不會 你相信我
你現在參加會員比
上個月參加會員的好
比最近參加會員的好
因為現在是好買一點
因為現在看起來
他的確要二次
有沒有二次崩盤
他就技術線圖來講的話
的確喔 因為現在大家已經有點心裡亂了
因為台灣股市現在
來 找不到一個很強的股票
上禮拜還有很多股票
比如337是精彩
對
要創新高嘛
前幾天還有嘛對不對
這兩天弱了嘛對不對
是
6196帆軒
是不是
還是很強 你看到
2377維新
你看還是股票創新高
這兩天都是大部分都回答
最強的股票都回答 你懂嗎
那一堆股票要死不活 跌很兇
來 我們跟你講
來
金居 8358金居 有沒有看到
反彈後死毛條
有沒有有點像國具
更慘對不對
是
金居你看
758跌到367 很慘啊
反彈後死貓跳
很多人怕台股就這樣子
反彈後犯大
反彈後死貓跳
逼迫反彈後再次破底
就是台灣股市會不會
我只能說有可能
可是我不在乎
因為AI的爛槽下
我已經算全台灣做用AI的分析師
AI的爛槽下
我覺得我非常
台灣股市非常機會
我不能用肯定兩個字接的嘛
但我非常有機會
我覺得台灣股市非常有機會
五年內甚至四年內十萬點
懂嗎
那你賺個2.5倍
在四年內賺2.5倍
你管他是四萬三還是四萬點
記得我的邏輯
為什麼回答
因為台灣股市現在已經漲50%了
已經漲50%了
我是用23%來算
漲50%很多
休息一下 沒什麼不好
OK嗎 記得我整個東西
現在幾分了
四點
蛤
五三四七世界先進也是一樣
那我要強調的時候
我覺得最看好的是環球金
目前為止
因為環球金跌比較兇
世界金也跌很兇
但環球金跌更兇
我們看一下
算一下好不好
大概30%嘛
你就是把它現在的價格
處理最高價
157處理223
來我教你
這邊是157有沒有看到
最高是223有沒有看到
放大
最近是157
沒關係 放大很大
現在是157
最高是223
那就157除以223
有沒有看到
打幾折
打7折
70%
這樣能不能懂
OK嗎
你年輕啊
是
其實機優股
大概回檔30%
那35%就可以買
就這麼簡單
好不好
新鮮器好像我們是在這邊買的
152買的
所以我們今天還是賺錢
都152買的人
好不好
所以拉回我就買
拉回我就買
就這麼簡單
我選的第一基期了
好不好
那我剛才罵國具不代表
國具一定不會漲下去
不過也不代表為什麼
因為如果台灣股市十萬點
他還是有可能1200
那你懂我意思嗎
對
他還是有
可是十萬點的時候
1200很多股票可能漲三倍了
漲四倍了
懂不懂意思
只是目前為止
短期內很難
很難就是一支獨秀
記得一件事
然後第二個你看一下春田製作所
春田製作所資金也回答40%
看一下好不好
把這些邏輯跟大家講
春田製作所走勢也很重要
所以一堆股票拉回的過程中我要買
小孩現在幾班呢
所以懂我的邏輯你就發現
跟人家不太一樣
等一下
電腦剛好彈掉
我結束了是不是
欸 真的淡掉了
為什麼骨牙沒講
第一次老天覺得我剛剛淡掉
不會 這電腦怎麼淡掉
沒事沒事
好
那我看一下要講什麼
小狼幫我用一下 看出淡掉
天啊
都不會動
根本誰還要留言上電視你知道嗎
好啦 結束了
結束了好不好 真的不會動嗎
他聲音有動啊
對啊 為什麼
可是其他不能動 你再幫我按一下
真的不能動就結束了 好不好
跟拔起來沒有關係啊
投資長他們知道今天晚上公司有活動
所以趕快 要結束了
電腦要休息了
沒有沒有沒有
我還是最後問大家看有沒有問題
剛好結束 OK了
尾創跟尾影
這則裝備金要加碼
要喔要要
環球金其實最好我去加碼環球金
因為環球金這次回答比較多
好不好
台政科
我第一優先責
來
細菁有環球的菁
在中美菁
好不好
在那個
在台政科
我的選擇這樣子
好不好
OK嗎
是跟大家講
有人說有沒有資源
來我看一下資源
資源今天才能漲
你告訴我為什麼資源今天能漲
你知道為什麼嗎
天啊
資源這一波根本沒漲
懂不懂
股票長
國際哪一天在跌到
跌到300塊
不要說300塊
400多塊 500塊
基本大概400多塊的時候
接近400塊的時候
其實你也可以買了啦
400塊多塊有機會漲一倍啦
有機會漲到八九百塊
你知道嗎
懂我意思嗎
只是他現在籌碼很亂
這有什麼
所以我就講股市節奏
漲多等他回檔
回檔的時候又逆買進
我現在看到機會
你看到是痛苦
你媽要參加我會員
你看到是機會
你說這這我要參加你會員
就像你看最近這個東西也是一樣
你看最近紅海也是慢慢拉起來
很多人說偽串可不可以買
要買偽串我不如買紅海
你知道嗎
紅海技術含量更大
好不好
這是我說的好不好
那偽串有沒有可能拉起來
也有可能
但是我覺得
重點是大盤要回穩
不論對我做我一切
在預告前面
再看一下我們股票的績效
這都實在的績效
好不好
這精彩環球金有沒有看到
現在賺100%
樊軒
好不好
還有聯發科
哇賺了100多%
國際賺100%
藍牙科賺60幾%
不只藍牙科
我兩次
三次加起來 260幾%
其實如果用負利來算的話
有可能接近300%
去想看你要怎麼分析
想清楚想明白
哇 哲哲你講得真對
我是看好你相信你講
哇 10萬點
我用 AI 真的未認同你講這東西
不論是 AI短矩或是醫療方面
那你想想看
很多更聰明的人
用 AI 超級 AI 發生的時候
你那時候股市已經 10萬點了
哲哲你講得真對
這時候是人生最大的獲利時候
所以我一定要趁大家回來的時候
我把它視為機會
成功的人是把痛苦視為機會
現在也不能算痛苦
可是把這個小小的回答
當作一個機會
歡迎來臨下情
0806-8085
加我LINE
私訊我
最偉大的AI行情
才正式要啟動
去想想看你要責任分析師
也預祝各位能夠賺大錢
我看到的機會
我看到的是我要賺大錢
你呢
謝謝各位
拜拜
本节目资料仅供参考
投资人应独立判断
审慎评估并自负投资风险
谢谢大家